[ cheers ]
TERRIFICO.
TAPPED OUT.
VANVLEET
THERE'S THE LOOK OFF YOU WERE
TALKING ABOUT.
>> Alvin: THAT'S THE LEFT AND GG
BETTER AT FINISHING.
LOGO.
FREDDIE LOGO! DEEP FROM
KEY WEST.
HERE ITT.
AND OUTED BOUNDS.
KEON JOHNSON
AND OUT OF
BEEN A FACTOR.
BUT THAT TIME YOU GET
FRED.
>> Jack: GREAT PASS.
>> Matt: AND A PRESENTING
HIMSELF AS A TARGET. REBOUND,
CHANCE TO RUN.THE GAME IS
PRESENTED BY YOUR WASHINGTON
AREA HONDA DEALERS.
HERE'S FRED.
MITCHELL ON HIM.
VANVLEET.
A LITTLE BIT OF BREATHING ROOM.
O
ANY  ARE WINNING PLAYS.
THAT'S WHAT I'M TALKING
THERE YOU GO.
ON THE RUN HELLO!
GORGEOUS PASS THAT TIME.
>> Matt: AND DES IN.
MILLS
BUT HOW ABOUT GETTING STOPS HER.
SIAKAM, THE SLAM DUNK.
>> Jack: WHAT GREAT OFFS GOT 1.
>> Jack: H
DEEP
RIGHT?
QUICK SKIP RIG
HERE'S TRENT IN THE
>> YOU
BIRCH WITH IT.
HAND OFF FRED.ING THE PAINT.
KEEPING HIS HEAD UP.
GETTING THE PAINT.
BOOM.
.
>> Justin: NINE POINTS FOR BOD
>> RAPTORS HAVE MADE EIGHT I'M
OVER THE PLACE.
HAVE BEEN DECIDED BY JUST 3 RIM.
FEEDING AHEAD, DRIVING,
AND THAT CUES VANVLEET UP FOR5-
>> Alvin: STAYING WITH IT.
DOING A GREAT JOB NOT GIVING UPA
REBOUND.
GOOD DEFENCE ON THE INSIDE BY
HEE
WARRIORS ARE BY CURRY.
BUT TONIGHT RAPTORS HAVE DONE A
URBAN.
MORANT GETS INSIDE.
WE KNOW HOW
PASCAL A GREAT CUT PLUS THE
FOUL.
>> Jack: WHAT ABY, KICK OUT, 3.
GOOD  SPACING.
>> Matt: FRED, GOOD
BACK NOW DRIVING.
SPINS.
LOSES IT. Alvin: GAFFORD IS A ST
FRED, TURNS, FIRES.